call your wife crazy and then ask her to
watch the Golden Globes with you I'm
going to watch the Globes you coming BR
because we have the final episode of
delicate part one and oh boy there's a
lot to talk about what is Anna coughing
up who is dex's Dad and why is my local
grocery store out of Ben and Jerry's I
should mention that as of the writing of
this video we don't have a release date
for part two with the actor strike still
going on we're probably looking at 2024
with that out of the way let's get into
the video I've left time stamps below so
you can see all the topics I'll be
covering oh and like And subscribe I do
plan on covering part two whenever it
comes out in the next decade well I
didn't have Carl loger Feld and Eve St
Lon my AHS bingo card this week these
famous designers have taken a young Miss
preacher under their wing in 1987
Manhattan and my God these nurses need
to learn some bedside Manor you're
having a fuing baby of course it hurts
Miss preacher will later tell Virginia
that this baby's father was a one- night
stand from a sailor during Fleet Week
while she'll tell Carl and Eve that the
father is quote stuck in traffic
regardless of who the father is Dr Hill
here says that Miss preacher cannot
reneg on her deal implying that she like
Queen Mary before her made a deal with
these Raven women in exchange for her
child Miss preacher would become a
famous designer selling her bag to Marc
Jacobs and making millions I also think
it's very weird Dr Hill hasn't aged here
at least not much he should be 36 years
younger putting him in his late 20s and
he definitely doesn't look it was this
simply a production choice that the
writers thought they could get away with
or does Dr Hill have some form of
longevity nothing's off the table when
you're working with a supernatural now
preacher ends up having this baby all we
really know is that it's a male from Dr
Hill exclaiming quote he's crowning we
don't even get to see if it has those
claw-like Talons like Queen Mary's baby
nor do we find out the fate of this
child with Miss preacher in Virginia
teaming up it makes me believe there's
more of a connection between these two
than meets the eye perhaps preacher is
dex's real mother it might explain why
preacher is so adamant about dex's
safety I'm telling you this because of
your son your son is in great danger and
the Very fact we have Virginia saying
this some men won't even stand up for
the woman who bursted them just makes me
question she might not be the mother we
still don't know who dex's dad is
Virginia wants Dex to testify in her
assault case against him cling that his
father performed Satanic rituals that
clouded her memory it was only when she
saw a psychotherapist that these
memories came back to her my best guess
at the moment is Dr Hill is dex's father
but Dex like his mother has had his
memory wiped we know that his father
must have been very affluent paying for
dex's schooling and an expensive condo
in the city Dr Hill has his own clinic
and could probably afford this in
episode one Dr Hill pays more attention
to Dex than to Anna his patient and only
when Dex gives him a glare this episode
as he further assess Anna and her pain
Miss preacher also regularly stops by
the clinic corus said she's just a crazy
woman who stops by all the time to hand
out conspiracy Flyers but what if she's
here to see Dr Hill what more of their
story are we missing after seeing her
lawyer Virginia experiences this
haunting it's as if the sights and
sounds of the city drown out around her
part of it looks like nighttime
pedestrians disappear and she's haunted
by images of a barking German Shepherd
black goats like those found on the
beach and four of these Raven women it
looks as though she's seen these women
before this is the first time we've seen
more than the two of them on screen
suggesting there are multiples of them
out there working for some greater
purpose we know two of them are the
Ashley Siobhan is probably their leader
but the final two are a mystery maybe
it's Nicollet and Sonia remember two
Ravens took Anna Nicolet basically lives
in the house and we learn this episode
that Sonia is only 15 minutes away
Siobhan is really really dialed up the
this episode being almost as cold
as a Ben and& Jerry's ice cream without
telling Anna she's taken on babet Eno as
a client this girl seriously licked
Anna's pastry and put it back but
why is Siobhan so damn pissed Anna
thinks it's because she got pregnant and
is jealous but honestly I'm not sure i'
buy that since Siobhan has been nothing
but supportive throughout Anna's IVF
treatment she's so nice she even gives
her more of that sweet vitamin B12 those
vials she gave Anna in episode 2 and you
know when they put in music like this it
can't be
good Siobhan taking on babet as a client
is most likely a setup to ensure Anna
does what it takes to get that Oscar the
evidence so far points at Siobhan being
either one of the Ravens or its leader
she tends to wear all black hires the
Ashley's who were present as Ravens with
Queen Mary and asks Anna if she wants a
baby as much as she does an Oscar Anna
Mary and preacher have all been given
something in exchange for their babies
Mary a fruitful Reign preacher success
in fashion and Anna success in acting
Siobhan also continues her romp with HH
but to be honest I don't quite know what
she's getting out of it we find out it
was Siobhan who gave HH the script for
the artour and told him to put his name
on it even after hamish's agents told
him that the film would go nowhere
especially with Anna in the lead It
defied All Odds and now has 11 Golden
Globe Noms it seems Siobhan is
orchestrating all of this and he demands
to know what's going on what the is
going on Sion and who the hell are you
not getting a huge part this episode is
Kamal who we learn has a wife of 5 years
I don't know about you but I felt this
was like an odd piece of information we
learn a bit more about nicholet however
when Sonia arrives Anna notes how odd
Nicollet looked at her almost as if she
had seen her before remember that
nicholet is talia's house manager so
it's easy to assume that Nicollet would
have known talia's best friend Adeline
so when she saw Sonia who is the
spitting image of Adeline it may have
triggered something in her even though
Nicollet says she's never met an Adeline
Anna still hasn't gotten rid of that
picture of Adeline and Dex last episode
we saw how Adeline morphed into Sonia
shawcross perhaps a manifestation of
Anna's paranoia that her husband is
cheating speaking of cheating Sonia
tells Anna that she's staying just 15
minutes away at a nearby Hotel this
totally isn't helping with those
cheating thoughts and who else lives
close by dex's there's a lot of
coincidences here in this episode we
have a new addition to the photo Ivy
we've seen how Ivy wants to make sure
that Anna does not have her child could
ivy have had something to do with
adeline's death all we really know is
that Adeline died in a tragic kitchen
fire at a restaurant where all the staff
were female and who the hell keeps
filling the fridge with ice cream that
is going to melt in her
conversation with Virginia preacher says
that this evil group is out to get Anna
and Dex as revenge for adeline's defense
inection the implication here is that
Adeline used to be one of the Ravens
before falling in love with Dex maybe
Adeline never died in that fire but
these Ravens somehow took back control
of her body she says this really weird
line about being the slightly more evil
version of Adeline which I thought was
weird Sonia also givs Anna a white owl
plushy a white owl was seen perched in
the forest when Anna Kamal and Dex go
searching for Miss preacher maybe Sonia
can shape shift into this animal last
episode we saw a black cat make its way
into the basement through the window is
that how these Ravens are getting in and
out with some sort of shape shifting the
name Sonia means wisdom and in many
cultures owls are a symbol of wisdom and
what about those green heels Sonia says
green heels you had on at the gallery oh
God I never wear green yet Anna saw her
wear green shoes at her exhibition and
outside her popup Gallery is Sonia lying
or Anna misremembering maybe Sonia is
simultaneously Sonia and Adeline
switching between these two
personalities Virginia hires a famous
lawyer Luther Feldman to help in her
case there's only one scene between
these two but honestly it doesn't
Advance the plot or provide us with
anything about this character perhaps
the writers wanted us to have a look at
him as he may play a bigger role in
episodes to come there's no confirmation
if he's related to Lark Feldman the
mysterious tattoo artist and dentist
played by Billy Lord in season 10's
double feature while getting examined Dr
Hill notes that the baby is growing
exceptionally fast thinking that Anna is
in her third trimester instead of second
could this demon baby be growing at a
faster rate than normal Anna's pimple
continues to bother her and she starts
losing her hair in the shower your body
will always tell you when something's
wrong isn't that the truth and as Spa a
is interrupted by shower goats and you
know that's got to be an extra charge
Anna also finds those dolls with pieces
of her hair missing we still don't know
who's been putting these here but they
seem to act like voodoo dolls can we
also talk about how uncomfortable this
scene with Cor was it doesn't really
move the plot along but it certainly
seems like a metaphor for consent or the
lack of it in Anna's case I should also
mention this fight between Dex and Anna
where Dex finally admits what we've
known all this time that he believes
Anna is making all this stuff up all
Anna wants is for Dex to believe her but
he's not sure he can do that so what do
you do when your husband doesn't believe
you you camp out in your creepy basement
where you've taken those anod dolls and
put them in the crib really not helping
your argument that someone else is
putting the dog out there Anna it's also
interesting to note that the raccoon is
gone did she actually eat that raccoon
last episode or was that a figment of
Her Imagination after getting knocked
unconscious Anna finds out that Babette
wins best actress and guess who calls
immediately after sioban it's almost as
if she knew this were going to happen
ready to ask Anna if she's willing to do
whatever she says to get that Oscar and
Anna wants it just as much as a baby now
what the hell does Anna cough up in our
first look at it appears to be tiny
screws or nails with grooves around the
edges kind of looks like it could be
whatever was nailed in the anadol found
on the beach if this indeed is some sort
of voodoo doll then coughing up these
nails or screws might be an answer but
this second shot doesn't look like a
nail or screw it's more smooth and
claw-like it looks too small to be a
raccoon claw and if it were to belong to
her baby who knows how it got into her
stomach another new addition is this
security camera the same one installed
by kamal's company in Anna's home I
don't think Kamal is here for Anna's
protection he's here to keep tabs on her
but thank goodness the security camera
is here because Anna appears to get
chloroformed judging by the gloves this
is either Dr Hill or one of the Ravens
he the nurses and Ravens all wear the
same type of gloves in the flashback
segment but take note of this orange
handkerchief orange being the same color
of Sonia's gift is Sonia one of the four
Ravens or is this just a coincidence
considering nothing was seen in the
security camera in episode two from the
break-in my guess is that nothing will
be seen here either Anna wakes up in a
completely different top than the one
she was knocked out in this kind of put
me on Red Alert thinking that Anna may
have been involved in be BET's death but
considering this happened right after
the Golden Globes which occur in
California and she's all the way over
here in the Hamptons this isn't likely
I'm curious how be BET's death will
strengthen Anna's chances at an Oscar
I'm assuming beet would be nominated too
and usually a death only stri
strengthens in nominees chances at
winning such was the case with Heath
Ledger and Chadwick Boseman Siobhan is
ready to get started as part one comes
to an end but now I turn it over to you
with several more months until part two
what are your biggest thoughts and
theories I want to hear them in the
comments below thanks for watching
please make sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
YT until next time remember Daddy loves
you very
much